can you think of any vertical videos
you've done that have been your highest
performing videos
and how those came together like what
was was it a trending audio and what are
some lessons that maybe some of your
breakout videos taught you yeah so
really it comes down to these four
things the first thing is that the video
had an element of polarity to it and by
polarity it kind of hit it in a couple
ways it was one the nature of the
content itself I was combining two
things that people would normally never
combine like Excel and dancing and that
sparked that conversation that got
people who you know might not even be
interested in Excel they're like what is
this girl doing you know and that really
is what got my videos off the ground and
then the video that I'm envisioning in
particular also had an additional layer
of polarity to it it's where I showed
how to do an Excel tip in one way where
there were like four other options so
instead of being like here are the four
ways you can break text out of yourself
it was I showed one way and by just
showing one it actually created
conversation around it because people
are like watching use flashville and not
the checks The Columns tool you know and
that also create a conversation a second
thing is the storytelling element so I
typically will jump into actual
characters especially if I want to
underlay trending music and do things
without speaking I'll just dress as
different characters label myself on the
screen and kind of create this narrative
around the content so that way even if
someone has seen that Excel tip before
they still might be commenting and
relating to it because they're like oh
like this has happened with my boss
before things like that third thing is
problem solving so making sure in the
first two seconds of that video I'm
showing a problem and quickly how I
solve it and then I get into the video
because that's usually my hook for
getting someone in especially in the
Excel space it's like how is this going
to save me time how is this going to
make me more efficient and then the
fourth thing really is just going in and
having that authentic energy so people
can tell on a subconscious subtle level
if you are uncomfortable on screen so I
will go through multiple times and make
sure that how I feel on the inside is
what is showing up on on the outside on
the other side of that screen because
that's what really builds that trust
with your audience right if someone's
looking a little Shifty on screen you
know like you might be like oh do I want
to buy their stuff you know so I spend a
lot of time cultivating the energy
within me so that when I come up on
Scream It's like bam you know someone
wants to enter the virtual world you
have created on the other side of that
screen